sister sister mother daughter duo tia
mori and jack hey harry are having the
ultimate 90s reunion yeah look at you
everybody knows the best things in life
come in twos earrings shoes pizzas uh
mom pieces don't come in twos well they
do when i order them
the pair couldn't have reunited at a
better location the set of tia's netflix
sitcom family reunion and while we wait
to see what unfolds from jack hay's
second appearance on the show i can't
believe you did that to your sister
sister
the gals took a little trip down sister
sister memory lane okay when did we
shoot the pilot was it nice
1996. i got married
now tia's twin tamara was nowhere in
sight but they were joined by her
co-stars loretta devine and talma
hopkins
and get this it looks like essence
atkins who worked with tia's younger
brother taj on smart guy is also making
a cameo on the show
and while we're grateful to see tia and
jack hay back on screen together we're
gonna have to be patient when it comes
to getting that sister sister revival
off the ground what are you saying what
i'm saying is
hi girls
last year while answering questions on
tick tock tia told fans it's not
happening
the silver lining nothing but love came
out of the beloved sitcom yeah isn't it
cool we'll be able to hang out like this
every day when e.t caught up with tia in
2020 she opened up about the tight bond
she has with the cast i truly do not
believe
i would be where i am today
if it weren't for
that
moment it was such a pivotal moment
within my career and not only that to be
working
with your twin to be working with your
sister
sister's sister really never felt like
work it was like a slumber party every
single day it was really like a family
and
even now i mean
i still get along and talk and keep in
contact with all of the cast members gay
tim marcus houston
my gosh what great memories do i have
working on that show and jack k she
looks back and smiles those girls are
magic and they didn't even know it and
they still don't know it you know i
think they kind of know it tia is very
savvy and tamara is a quirky one i
always know the difference you know so
it's just an image that you you know
like even not looking at you you just
like looking at them they were you i
didn't think that we were you know
imparting anything special but looking
back i see it like i said just a normal
family you know with no drama you know
no
cussing and fighting and stealing and
scrapping you know and shaking your head
and go to the hand and you know
so uh i see it now and i'm very proud of
it
[Music]
you